was ist das worin wir uns bewegen
wirklichkeit erfassen lässt sich die
welt nicht über augen- oder verstand um
zu verstehen was in ihr wirkt brauchte
sympathie einfühlungsvermögen wir sind
wie die fische in einer bekannten
parabel ein aufruf zu mehr empathie
schwimmen zwei junge fische des weges
und häfen zufällig einen älteren fisch
denn die gegenrichtung unterwegs ist er
nickt ihnen zu und sagt morgen jungs wie
ist das wasser die zwei jungen fische
schwimmen eine weile weiter und
schließlich dürfte eine dem anderen
einen blick zu uns sagt was zum teufel
ist was die fische erkennen gar nicht
dass sie im wasser leben
perspektivenwechsel weg von den
standardeinstellungen im kopf wir sehen
durch abstrakte ideen das ändert was wir
sehen wie wir sehen wir verlieren zugang
zu das was man wie man es sagen könnte
empathisch wahrgenommen wird
das sind gefühle zürich seit ende der
70er wahlheimat des psychoanalytikers an
ogone in berlin als sohn jüdischer
eltern geboren 1936 in die usa emigriert
ein zivilisationskritik außenseiter
unermüdlicher mahner empathie mitgefühl
ist sein lebensthema
arno brown lenkt das egozentrische
denken in die richtung einer empathisch
geprägten welt sich vor wenigen tagen
wurde er 90 jahre alt sein neuestes werk
dem leben entfremdet warum wir wieder
lernen müssen zu empfinden ist ein
leidenschaftliches plädoyer für empathie
radikal und irgendwie zärtlich der
mensch ist gut
von anfang an jeder mensch ist sein
eigener gott sagt arne krohn
empathie ist eine angeborene fähigkeit
liebe und wärme braucht es um sie zu
erhalten
aber bei uns im westen drängen wir das
empathische zurück machen die kinder zu
funktionierenden rädchen eines systems
leben in dieser kultur von das mit
wettbewerbern zu tun hat erleben wir
auch kinder als ob die uns etwas
absetzen möchten so dass der wettbewerb
existiert da schon wenn sich schreien
müssen wir deswegen ihren willen in
griff kriegen und wir lassen sich rein
es gibt viele kulturen
die kinder scheinen
viele sind als original geboren sterben
als coupé das war etwa die an
viele menschen sind so sind einfach
kopien die natürliche angeborene
empathie gehe durch kulturelle einflüsse
in den ersten jahren verloren
wirft ein neues licht auf die kaum mehr
hinterfragten grundprinzipien dieser
kultur die welt in der wir leben ist
bestimmt von kampf wettbewerb
profitieren aber nicht kampf und
konkurrenz sind die triebkräfte unserer
existenz das für uns entwickelten als
menschen kam zustande durch kooperation
nicht durch wettbewerb es kam zustande
durch dadurch dass menschen sich
einander geholfen haben
nicht dass der stärkere den nicht
starken unterdrückte empathie ist nicht
nur die grundvoraussetzung für seelische
gesundheit sondern auch für demokratie
die welt aus der sicht eines anderen
sehen
eine indianische redensart sagt in den
mokassins eines anderen gehen
wir haben das verlernt das macht uns
krank
doch es formieren sich neue soziale
bewegungen die kritik wächst der sich
öffnenden schere zwischen arm und reich
empathie hat politische dimensionen nach
kronen leben wir in einer durch
konstruierten welt unfähig lebendig
mitfühlend die wirklichkeit wahrzunehmen
freiwillige knechtschaft wurde das auch
schon genannt
dagegen kämpft anna grund kreativität
ist das wichtige und nicht gehorsam
hängt uns ein meint nur dass wir genauso
werden oder wie die die uns bestimmen
die macht über uns haben und das verdikt
dieses system
kreativität ist ja immer ein versuch aus
dem gefängnis dieser kulturen
auszutauschen so es ist ein dauernder
kampf ist stimmt der kampf ist da so
markus weiter kämpfen
es ist nicht vergeblich